frankie ricky in his 16th year at the
big league level he's 36 years old
and he drives this one down the left
field line tucker on the movie can't get
it on the dive
it's gonna roll up against the wall and
yasrimski is going to go for three
and he is going to make it
so your shrimsky 90 feet away for alex
dickerson the left fielder
[Applause]
there's a line drive into center field
base hit
just in front of miles straw and in the
score is jazz
and two batters in the giants have a one
to nothing lead
swing and a miss got him on a good
fastball had some downward movement
might have even been the changeup yeah
on the hill tonight for the giants will
be trevor cahill cahill in his 11th year
at the big league level 6-4 225 pounder
he's
32 years of age get on the ground to
crawford on the backhand
his overhand throw in time one out
he got him it was unbelievable
hit right back to cahill and the damage
is just one walk
struck out 13 times and 45 at bats
swinging and a miss cranky gets him
again
and his strikeout number two and two
away in the second
the one tooth got him good
change up springer very
very dangerous enormous power bases
loaded here's the pitch
who's got it it's dubai
and a nice job by anderson to retire
springer the astros leave them loaded
the last thing the hitter needs is
another opportunity to have the wheels
spinning
swinging a myth grenkey picks up a
strikeout three strikeouts for zach
one in every inning and one away here in
the third we saw this with zach on the
road trip he does like to work out of
the wind up when he can a runner on
third base here
in a 3-2 count swinging a miss there he
goes with the infield drawn in he takes
care of hunter pence on strikes so here
is dickerson
who has singled home the only run of the
game
swinging in a mess got him to chase a
change up off the plate away
and dickerson is down on strikes fifth
strikeout for granky and there are two
out
delivers a 2-2 and that's lifted into
left-center field racing over tucker and
he reaches down makes the catch goes
into a tumble holds on to the baseball
low line drive tucker got a good jump
and the giants are turned to side
all right springer at second redick at
first one nothing giants one out for the
astros in the bottom of the fifth and
bregman up
up the middle base hit for bregman great
jump by springer he is going to score
easily george crosses the plate with the
astros first run
we're tied at one
get on the ground that's one
that's two it's been like we said that
start
was kind of the last one if you will at
the end of his spring training or maybe
his first start of the regular season
just based on where he was
stamina wise and now he gets brandon
bell on a foul tip
strikeout he has six strikeouts now one
in
every inning as he strikes out belt to
start the six
swing and a miss he gets longoria
chasing back-to-back strikeouts for
greggy he's now struck out three of the
last four batters things happening right
here
in the sixth inning for the houston
astros all right so maldonado will hit
here
that one scoots through here comes
correa carlos is going to score with a
head first slide
astros take the lead 2-1 the kick and
the pitch
and maldonado hits it in the air deep to
left field that sends back dickerson
looking up
see you later a three-run home run for
martin maldonado
and the astros go up 5-1
boy the astro needed that maldonado
comes up big
with two strikes shortens up and gets it
on the barrel
frankie may be getting near the end of
his rope here
oh my everybody knows what sign they're
going with now
this is incredible he told everybody
what signs are going
works it pops them up who wants it
josh reddick calls off everybody another
entertaining night watching zach greggy
pitch baseballs tonight this guy is
incredible
you have he's must see tv for me now
slowly hit past taylor the second
baseman toro gets to make his first play
of the night
and there's one away
that ball slicing away from reddick long
run for josh he'll get there
almost over ran it but that works for
the final out
of the ball game a big exhale from
reddick the astros win the series as
they take tonight's game 5-1